same country same crisis different
advice on the weekend the guidance
changed in one corner of the United
Kingdom and the others it stayed the
same outside of England it's not stay
alert it still stay at home you did say
last week to drop the stay-at-home
message would be potentially
catastrophic is the Prime Minister
quoting catastrophe I don't know what
stay alert means presumably we all live
our lives and normal times staying away
up to danger but if I say to you my
message now is stay alert and you say to
me but does that mean I stay at home or
not
I can't give you a straight answer to
that and therefore I am feeling in my
duty to be clear in terms of what I'm
asking you to do when people stay at
home it makes a massive difference in
Scotland they'll stick with the current
public health information campaign
Nicola Sturgeon has asked the UK
government not to promote its stay alert
slogan north of the border in Wales in
Northern Ireland - they're sticking with
stay at home concerns are echoed
throughout the devolved Nations the
message I will be giving to people in
Wales is is while they must be alert to
the continuing danger of coronavirus if
you're not out of your house for an
essential purpose and that does include
exercise that can include shopping and
it can must include going to work for
people who can safely do so staying at
home remains the best way that you can
protect yourself and others
amidst the crisis politics what of the
people it comes down after all - what
they do with the information fake act in
Heian why near the border between
England and Wales the people we spoke to
wanted a single message I think I sure
get together now the same ruling you
know what like Wales Scotland Ireland
and England they can't separate although
they are they shouldn't they should do
Duke they should be in this together we
can't be doing something different in
Wales - in England it's just not
feasible you know it's such unknown
territory for everyone that if the
message is confused again I don't think
it's really
fare on anyone the single for nations
approach continues for now but it's
clear it is being tested here in
Scotland Nicola Sturgeon has said that
progress mustn't be squandered by mixed
messages warning that people will die
unnecessarily clarity of message he said
was paramount a clarity that's less
clear today perhaps than it was
yesterday
James Matthews Sky News